jacques chirac ne peut pas être
poursuivi par les juridictions
ordinaires pendant l'exercice de ses
fonctions présidentielles c'est ce qu'a
confirmé ce matin la chambre
d'accusation de la cour de versailles
une cour qui va en grande partie dans le
même sens que l' ordonnance rendue dans
le dossier des emplois présumés fictifs
du rpr des précisions avec olivier carf
jacques chirac n'a rien à redouter des
juges d'instruction mais pour combien de
temps la justice vient de donner une
réponse
l'immunité ne durera que le temps du
mandat présidentiel
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de versailles devait se
prononcer sur la sphère des emplois
fictifs du rpr
un dossier où figurent des documents
pouvant impliquer jacques chirac
un dossier qui vaut déjà à plusieurs
personnalités du parti gaulliste une
mise en examen ce matin après l'audience
leurs avocats se faisait plutôt discret
j'ai pas de commentaire à faire
je fais des commentaires dans les salles
d'audience j'en fais pas partie civile
dans la sphère militants écologistes
parisiens vais demander la mise en
examen de jacques chirac ou en tout cas
son audition sa demande est rejetée
mais pour lui l'essentiel est ailleurs
en clair l'instruction va continuer son
cours normalement et nous serons disons
tout le temps dans la partie civile
la seule chose que l'on peut pas c'est
pour l'instant mettre en examen jacques
chirac pendant la durée de son mandat
mais ensuite on verra bien dire que
l'action publique continue et jacques
chirac pour être éventuellement inquiété
plus tard à l'issue de son mandat
jacques chirac pour être éventuellement
inquiété à la fin de son mandat s'il est
pas réélu le juge des murs chargés de la
faire et donc encourager à continuer son
enquête
y compris sur la partie du dossier qui
concerne directement le président de la
république